autre procès à marseille cette fois ci
dans la sphère des profanateurs de
carpentras le grand rabbin de france
joseph sitruk est intervenu au deuxième
jour de ce procès il n'est pas venu
réclamer une sanction mais il a souhaité
que ces jeunes gens reçoivent tu me
leçon valérie ermite dominique
verdeilhan à d'autres récits pas de
paroles des profanateurs ce matin tous
ont écouté le grand rabbin de france
dans le témoignage à l'audience fut
hautement symbolique
je veux surtout dire que c'est pas le
procès de la communauté c'est le procès
de la france c'est important c'est en
fait l'humanité qui est ici en jeu a
beaucoup plus que calum joseph sitruk a
stigmatisé la lâcheté du geste c'est un
cri de révolte que je pousse au nom de
ceux qui ne peuvent plus le faire
c'est plus qu'une communauté qui a été
insulté c'est la france c'est un pays
tout entier qu'il faut réhabiliter et
c'est à l'humanité qu'il faut redonner
de l'espérance
quelque part ils vont grandir avec le
mépris de l'autre ils vont grandir avec
la haine et la haine il faut savoir
l'extirper du coeur
l'extirper du club peut-être les aider
faut les aider par une leçon pour les
aider par un enseignement doit surtout
dire que pour moi l'histoire c'est pas
seulement les faits c'est les leçons que
l'on en retire si beaucoup plus qu'une
sanction que j'attende est il au
tribunal
c'est une leçon et si elle est comprise
tout le monde aura gagné
puis il s'adresse aux profanateurs c'est
vrai vous n'avait tué personne mais
finalement vous avez tué tout le monde
chapitre social match